-There are shocking new details
in the investigation of
the January 6th insurrection,
including a PowerPoint plan
for overturning the election
and an attempt to intimidate
a Georgia election worker,
that make it very clear
Donald Trump and his gang
were trying to stage a coup
and came very close
to succeeding.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
As we near
the one-year anniversary
of the Capitol insurrection,
it's important to remember
just how terrifying
and unpredictable that day was.
For example, I remember,
instead of taping our show
in the afternoon,
we postponed it
and did it live that night
because there was no way
of knowing
how things were going to end.
And we never postpone
our tapings
because we all
have places to be.
I have to get home to my family.
Shoemaker has to get
to the dog track.
Jim and John,
our security guards,
have to get to the dog track.
The crew has to get to the d--
It's mostly dog track related.
I should clarify,
they don't go to bet on dogs.
They go to rescue them, but I do
not think it's going very well.
Every morning, they show up
with fresh scratches.
When we try to find out
what happened,
they just say, "Don't ask."
Point is, it's important
to remember January 6th
and to document each time
new details emerge,
which, incredibly,
continues to happen,
with each piece
of new information
being more insane than the last.
I don't know how it's possible.
It's like "Succession."
Just when you think
it's getting repetitive,
they find a new way
to shock you.
And, by the way, I haven't seen
last night's episode yet,
so no one spoil it for me.
I don't want anyone
shouting out plot twists,
and I certainly don't want Wally
teasing me via cue card.
Wally, no!
[ Laughter ]
Do we have to eat later after
Wally made a meal of that?
The point is,
it is now beyond doubt,
if there was any to begin with,
that Trump and his gang
tried to stage a coup
to overturn
a presidential election.
They came incredibly close
to pulling it off.
And it's very likely
they'll try again.
In fact, we know Trump
would like to try it again
because he keeps
talking about it,
as he did over the weekend
at a so-called history tour
with disgraced former
Fox News host Bill O'Reilly.
-Mike, had he had the courage
to do what Thomas Jefferson did
but a minor version --
You know, Thomas Jefferson,
he kept Georgia.
You know that?
He didn't send it back.
There was a dispute.
Hear ye, hear ye.
The great state of Georgia
is unable to properly
calculate its votes.
Thomas Jefferson was sitting
where Mike was,
right where Mike --
You know what he said?
"Hear ye, hear ye.
We will keep the votes
of the great state of Georgia."
He didn't send it back
to the legis-- No.
All I wanted and a lot of people
wanted Mike to do
is send them back.
-I'll say this --
He's the only guy I've ever seen
do an episode of "Drunk History"
stone-cold sober.
I mean, it's like watching
an amnesia patient
wander up onstage during
a performance of "Hamilton."
-Secretary Jefferson,
you have the floor, sir.
-Hear ye, hear ye.
-It's, frankly, hilarious
that the only thing
Trump seems to know
about American history
is that people used to say,
"Hear ye, hear ye."
And he probably only knows that
from one of those commercials
where the owner
of a local car dealership
dresses up as a founding father
for an ad
advertising
a Presidents' Day sale.
"Hear ye, hear ye!
Come on down
to ye olde Joey Petrocelli's
Kia dealership of Staten Island.
These prices are so low,
you'll have to two it by land,
one if by sea...for yourself."
By the way, Trump is referencing
a debunked theory
floated by his supporters
that Thomas Jefferson
somehow used his power
as vice president
overseeing the counting
of electoral votes in 1800
to make himself president,
a theory disproven by,
among others,
an article with the headline...
It's a real sign of the times
how many headlines
sound like they should start
with a big old, heavy sigh.
With all due respect
to O'Reilly and Trump,
we might as well
get our history tour
from a gym teacher
who had to sub in last-minute
because the real teacher
had a COVID exposure.
"Who we doing today, Jefferson?
Okay, bear with Coach
because it's been a while
since I cracked open
them history books.
Oh, boy. If memory serves,
Jefferson ran on two platforms.
One, don't let fish fry
in the kitchen,
and, two, don't let beans
burn on the grill.
And after his presidency,
he moved on up to the east side,
okay.
To Monticello,
which is what he called
his deluxe apartment in the sky.
Alright, let's do laps!"
By the way...
...while we're talking about it,
I just feel like
it's worth pointing out
that ticket sales for this
Trump/O'Reilly history tour
have been lackluster.
Photos of the first event
in Sunrise, Florida,
showed lots of empty seats
in the arena,
and the "South Florida
Sun Sentinel" reported that...
Yikes! I mean,
there was better attendance
at my son's kindergarten
holiday pageant --
or there would have been had it
not been canceled due to COVID,
which is a real shame, because
my son would have killed it
as a wise man, because I've been
teaching him my Pacino.
[ As Pacino ] Whoa,
did somebody order the myrrh?
Joseph, that kid
does not look like you.
[ Normal voice ]
The juxtaposition --
[ As Pacino ] Jo--
We got to talk to Joseph.
No, frankincense won't fix it."
[ Normal voice ]
The juxtaposition here
is so revealing
because it's
a vivid demonstration
of how deeply unpopular he is,
which is why he needed to stage
a coup to stay in power.
And we have
overwhelming evidence
that that's exactly
what happened.
They did everything they could,
left no stone unturned,
looked for every crack
and crevice in our democracy
they could possibly find.
Their lawyers filed tons
of bogus lawsuits
and flew around the country
trying to get lawmakers
to overturn
their state's results,
forced an unnecessary recount
in Georgia
to confirm Biden's win
a third time,
pressured the governor
to call a special session
to reject the votes,
tried to send alternate slates
of electors to D.C.,
leaned on the Georgia
secretary of state
to find enough votes
to overturn the result,
tried to get the U.S. attorney
to announce
that there was widespread fraud,
tried to get
the Justice Department
to declare that there was fraud,
wrote memo after memo
laying out steps Mike Pence
could have taken
to overturn the result,
called up individual senators
to get them to reject
the electoral votes,
and called Mike Pence
into the Oval Office
to personally bully him
into rejecting the results.
Trump tried
so many different avenues.
He was like the guy
at the grocery store
during the Christmas rush
who keeps switching
checkout aisles.
You got to wait, buddy.
There's no secret line that's
shorter than the other lines.
You don't like lines, go fight
with the self-checkout machine
like everyone else.
-Please place your item
in the bag.
-I already bagged it.
-Please place your item
in the bag.
-It's in the bag!
-Please wait for assistance.
-Son of a bitch!
And when Pence said
he didn't have that power,
Trump even went so far
as to say...
Did he say that while
peeking over his sunglasses,
"Risky Business" style?
It's so disorienting for things
to be both this dangerous
and this dumb at the same time.
Like, how are we supposed
to process this?
It was both
a very real coup attempt
that continues to pose
a clear and present danger
to our democracy
and also one of the dumbest
things to ever happen.
It's like if you found out
this guy
was a prolific serial killer.
-Whaa!
[ Crowd groans ]
-Like, all the defense
would have to do
is show that video and say,
"You really think my client
is capable of luring innocent
victims into his basement?
He tried to cannonball
through the ice."
And then that guy would say,
"I would never want
to break the ice.
That's where the bodies are."
And the lawyer would be like,
"Shh!"
He's like, "No,
you have to keep them there
or else they start to smell."
It's a f-- we're having fun.
Look.
And yet somehow things
keep getting
both more dangerous and dumber,
'cause in the last few days,
we've learned
some shocking new details,
including the existence
of a truly insane
PowerPoint presentation
that was circling in Trumpworld
laying out the steps for a coup.
-Another shocking twist
in the January 6th investigation
now places
a retired U.S. Army colonel
at the center of efforts
to overturn the 2020 election.
"The Washington Post" reporting
Phil Waldron,
who circulated a proposal to
challenge the election results,
visited the White House many
times after Joe Biden's victory.
And during those visits,
he allegedly spoke
with former White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows
"between 8 and 10
separate times,"
worked alongside
Trump's legal team,
and even briefed
several members of Congress
on the eve of the insurrection
about how to stop
the election's certification.
-This is that 38-page
PowerPoint presentation,
unlike any other PowerPoint you
or I have ever seen, I'm sure,
that includes options
like President Trump
declaring a national emergency
to stop that from happening.
And "The Washington Post"
is reporting that Waldron
personally spoke to Meadows
about this PowerPoint.
-That's right --
They wrote down their plans
for a coup in a PowerPoint.
You know what that means
Congress is going to
have to subpoena Clippy.
That's from our new segment
"Jokes From 1995."
Now, famously, Trump never
writes anything down,
but I guess he forgot
to tell his underlings
before they started
e-mailing a PowerPoint around
detailing their crimes.
Even the mafia knows
to use code words.
If the Mafia ever made
a PowerPoint presentation,
it would say
something vague like...
"Okay, boss,
what's the next slide?"
"There's no more slides.
There's just the one slide."
All of that weren't
already insane enough,
we also have this bizarre
plot twist involving a publicist
who tried to pressure
a Georgia election worker
into publicly confessing
to bogus fraud charges.
-Well, it sure looks
like another piece
of the Trump coup plot
is exposed in Georgia.
-Bombshell reporting
from Reuters.
A Kanye West publicist pressured
a Georgia election worker
to confess to bogus
election fraud
two days before January 6th.
-We come to a woman
named Ruby Freeman.
She is a Georgia
election worker.
She was smeared by,
among others, Donald Trump,
who mentioned her name
18 times in that phone call
to the secretary of state.
A woman named Trevian Kutti
showed up at
Ruby Freeman's doorstep.
She said she was representing
a high-profile individual
who wanted to help Freeman.
What Kutti did not reveal
is that she was a publicist
to Kanye West,
a Trump ally who himself
ran a halfhearted campaign
for president in 2020.
So she agrees to meet
with Kanye's publicist
in a safe location,
a local police station,
where Kutti outlined a threat
wherein mysterious figures
would show up to Freeman's house
and put her
and her family in jail
if she did not publicly admit
to stealing the election
for Joe Biden.
-The president and his gang
tried every avenue
they could possibly find
to stage a coup
to overturn an election.
They came very close
and they'll try again.
They tried so many things, even
Kanye's apparently involved now,
although he legally
changed his name,
so when Trump introduces him
now, he probably says...
-Hear ye, hear ye.
-Been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over 2 million
meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.